[Music]
all right
welcome back to the break room everybody
It's Our Daily Show today
news you need to know uh with Halloween
out of the way it's Christmas time it's
Christmas maybe November 1st it's the 65
Days of Christmas
okay
welcome we're we're happy to have you on
today's show we got some new horror
updates uh some DC you news and Lincoln
out of James Gunn's Twitter account uh
of course the the title and thumbnail of
this video what is Cassie laying up to
we've got some really fun speculation I
bet it's no good we're still cooking
we'll find out what is she cooking black
panther 3 three
and uh uh and we have a super special
guest you might notice there's a gap
there in the middle of the table it's
not because uh Jessica and Tommy are
feuding it's because we're saving room
Tommy don't bake on this um we're saving
room for we have a super special guest
he's he or she is going to appear in the
latter third of the episode all the
rockstars fans are going to be thrilled
let's put it this way you better watch
out yeah
I'm telling you okay let's get into the
headlines oh baby
oh I didn't introduce them I was going
to say um okay and of course with me I
mentioned uh Tommy and Jessica are here
and Brandon Barrick down there at the
end you didn't I'm Zach Huddleston and
again we have a uh an extra special
guest there's so much we got so much to
talk about in this episode uh Lupita
Nyong'o who of course is in the news
right now for black panther what kind of
forever but she's also in the news
because she's just been cast in a quiet
place spin-off film called a quiet place
day one at Paramount now this is um day
one I think denoting like right when the
[ __ ] hits yeah like they did 28 Days
Later 28 Weeks Later and then I think
they may have made it directed to like
sequel that was like this is the process
of what happened in those 28 days but
yeah this seems like this is the first
day of whatever this invention a quiet
place too flashed back with John
Krasinski and Emily Blunt's characters
too like the day that it first happened
before then flashing forwards after the
events the first movie so I guess but
this could be anywhere else in the world
that is not like their Upstate New York
town or whatever is this going to turn
into The Walking Dead where we're just
gonna get a constant sprawl of quiet
place events I hope so I think so I
think it's just going to go bounce off
of every state I mean Cloverfield Lane
basically does that that's true I hope
that I hope we get the entire nations
all the quiet places an ignorant
question about the quiet place yeah does
it exist all over the world do we know
if it would the events of the film are
happening all over the world I think so
yeah because in a quiet place too they
kind of discuss how it starts over the
radio station and it's starting in this
they're like listening and they're like
oh this is acting weird and it's a
baseball game and then all hell breaks
loose and they find that they find an
isolated island that has yet to be
touched by the monsters or whatever
um but there's also quiet place three in
development so that that is like
continuing the timeline this will be
kind of going backwards in the timeline
anyways we're excited we love Lupita
niago and uh we're down for The Quiet
Place franchise oh the quiet places they
may go am I right guys you're right hope
you're having a great Tuesday uh
speaking of horror franchises we're very
excited for we got confirmation of when
The Last of Us HBO series is going to
come out so we drop in January 15th what
a nice way to kick off five days after
my birthday hey
um of course the series is going to air
on HBO Max we here in New rockstars are
going to be covering this it's a lot of
intersections and things we love gaming
horror franchising being the last of
something
big fans of us us all the words in the
title
um yeah that in that that crew the
people making it
um are great like isn't that Craig Mason
is involved with that from Chernobyl I
believe yes it was so good Chernobyl so
good so good let's not forget Craig
Mason also from The Hangover okay did he
write The Hangover I think he wrote the
first hangover oh wow
[Music]
what a diverse career that gentleman has
incredible um but yeah we're uh we're
very excited and Ted Cruz's college
roommate at Harvard no uh is it true
that is true wow yeah
I'm the master of facts
uh fact Master uh James Gunn recently
named head of DC films yeah uh on on
Twitter yesterday during Halloween he
had a fun post there it is posting uh
that is the DC character dead man
now so oh no I mean like I was I was
stretched all the way over to see it I
can't see it
I just gave up I think yeah
wait of all the time that's what breaks
yeah that's what breaks me so yeah the
angles here on this year I'm sorry but
uh dead man uh slightly lesser known uh
but interesting DC character could this
be James Gunn hinting at some plans for
the future of DCU I mean that's the
trouble with James Gunn's Twitter right
sometimes it's a Easter egg sometimes
it's a Easter nag I mean like it's
nothing but I will say I would love to
have man to get involved watch justice
league dark uh the anime some of the DC
animated stuff justice league dark the
DC animated movies are a dead man is
pretty funny he's kind of didn't take
over Batman
yeah he possesses oh yes yeah yeah I
don't in those movies I don't think he
does maybe he does but in those movies
he's very referential like almost like a
Ryan Reynolds type like very
quick-witted very funny almost comic
relief but also very effective because
he's a dead I mean like his power is
he's literally a ghost in the comics
he's uh sad and horrible yeah well I did
I did have to look up his uh his history
because I was not familiar with that man
I looked him up on uh the fandom Wiki
and he uh he has an origin story where
he was a trapeze artist who was killed
by a mysterious assailant named The Hook
but like how many Heroes started out as
trapeze artist yeah
it's because back in the day well if
you're gonna have somebody an awesome
fighter you need to justify that like
being like you're either a soldier or a
trapezer or a circus circus I was about
to say was it uh uh well I guess
Nicholas Cage's wasn't he in the surgery
oh that's right Ghost Rider yeah
Nicholas Cage version yeah
I feel like there's a lot of people
Comics actually eventually make their
ways in the circuses because they just
need like gymnast and the gymnast well
you can even go deeper in that
theorizing with like the reason we have
costume Heroes is because like when
comic books started the most mysterious
thing were these like traveling circuses
yeah or the strong men would dress up in
these outfits and like that's how
initially like comic book characters
became to be like right with his Heights
and yeah that's like where the ideas
came from and it's kind of universal
shared language of like powerful people
with special abilities yeah oh that's
great so whatever whatever it means he
could have also just been uh trolling us
a little bit or picking a Randomness
we're excited and again he was just
named him and Peter saffron just named
head of DC films we don't know what
they're gonna do yet but we're excited
to hear
um in other DC news Kristin miliati who
um I know from Palm Springs yes other
folks might recognize both of Wall
Street is called the resort or something
I believe yeah she she was also wasn't
she the mother the titular mother and
How I Met Your Mother that is correct
yes she just cast as Sophia Falcone in
the Batman spin-off series The Penguin
that is coming up on HBO Max uh Falcone
or Falcons
I know I know Italian people usually
pronounce
um a penguin
can you read recite that again
nope I'll leave that for Tommy uh but
she's um uh she's been cast and she's
been uh announced that she's been
playing the role of uh the daughter you
know of the Gotham my boss Carmine
Falcone who was played by John tutaro in
the Matt Reeves Robert Pattinson film so
in the Canon of that movie she is
I think in Gotham now correct me if I'm
wrong in the chat I know you will I can
always count on you guys for that Sophia
Falcone was in a relationship with Jim
Gordon in that TV show and then Salvador
moroni's son was in a relationship with
Lee uh Tompkins who was uh with Jim
Gordon and Lee Tompkins were like they
split off and dated the mobster's kids
uh and then they got married in real
life uh the guy from the OC and the
woman from Deadpool Marina Baccarin okay
that guy but I think yeah we've seen
that character before in the Gotham TV
show okay yeah I I hope that
establishes that uh Carmine Falcone gave
birth to everyone involved in Batman
yeah yeah this is this is Dick Grayson
my secret son he's he's an abrahamic
like figure
um but also it's interesting right
because in Canon Carmine falcony's dead
yeah
um but if she's around right and the
Penguins kind of taking over the
territory of Carmine Falcone right could
she be an adversary for the penguin
possibly she I mean she would do a great
job pretending to be like oh I don't
really want it and then being secretly
ruthless like oh my dad was a bad man
and then you find out she's just
freaking running stuff I sometimes get
this actress confused with Kate micucci
who they also they have similarities
have big eyes yes they both have very
large eyes brunette actresses
that's right well I mean we don't know
about um okay in an interview with
collider uh Nate Moore who's uh the
number two or number three man over at
Marvel under Kevin feige
um had had a fun quote about Sam
Wilson's relationship with Thunderbolt
Ross we know uh our our dude uh Harrison
Ford is gonna be playing Thunder Ross in
the upcoming uh Thunderbolts possibly
showing up in Captain America New World
Order we don't know
um well I think they did say he would be
in great world order maybe in
Thunderball yes but he's part of this
weird cast of doing order that includes
the leader that's just growing and it's
just like bizarre yeah yeah and poor Sam
Wilson is like can I be in this movie am
I still Captain America well well we're
all your Captain America yes let's just
hearing Sam stands uh that uh and
Sebastian sandstands
um stand stance all the stands out there
uh huddle stands even hey Nate more
ahead just to say uh he said Sam Wilson
is Captain America he's going to bring
his own team to play to see Sam Wilson
and Thunderbolt Ross which if you
remember thunderbol Ross actually threw
Sam into prison at the end of uh Civil
War because he violated the sokovia
Accords he was on uh Team cap there uh
so there's going to be some natural
Sparks there which I think are going to
be really fun now we know the sokovia
Accords are done thanks to a quick line
on Shield yeah
the most important thing that's been a
part of the Marvel Universe for almost a
decade is just not not there no we don't
know they might have been replaced with
something yeah that's right yeah the
Wachovia records
they'll walk over your records or the
Wachowski uh Accords yeah yeah
um make everything The Matrix Cloud
Atlas Sextant okay all right uh we got
to uh it just means a song Jessica I'm
read a book
listen to your book uh we've got some
excited we've got some exciting uh what
kind of forever headlines but first we
want to shout out the second season of
the hit show DC's Batman the audio
Adventures which is out now on HBO Max
speaking of of Batman and HBO Max uh
Gotham City a season cauldron of crime
and Corruption about to boil over in the
long shadow of Two-Face and the Penguins
combined criminal might Gotham City is
gripped in Twin fists of passion and
Terror as harleen quinzel bulldoze is a
path to her heart's desire in scarecrow
floods the city with new and improved
nightmares
tune in for a tale of uh life and death
in Gotham City uh this series stars
Jeffrey Wright Rosario Dawson Bradley
Whitford Gillian Jacobs Keenan Thompson
and Chris Parnell a really talented uh
voice staff uh and friend of the channel
Bobby Moynihan confirmed new Rockstar's
viewer Bobby Moynihan come on the show
Bobby uh plays the penguin in this
series uh he said in an interview with
TV Insider that it's a role he's most
proud of in his career stream DC's
Batman the audio Adventure season two
now on HBO Max now you might not be used
to writing audio content on HBO magic
shocked but they got it on there which
is awesome I was shocked uh yeah can I
see the face of what you made when you
saw it all right I was on the phone and
I was like
there it is
back back to headlines here undeniable
uh we got a fun quote uh from again from
Nate Moore Marvel executive talking
about how basically Ryan coogler put
dibs on uh Memoir uh six years ago I
like that that's how it works at
Marvel's the studio there's like a big
wall with names and then Post-it notes
and you just I think it's also good to
just do as much research as you can I
finished the headline then we can get
into it I'm sorry uh no no um in
post-production on the first black
panther film he was he basically Ryan
coogler the director basically said hey
if we get to make another one can I just
raise my hand and make sure no one else
uses that more uh and nobody else did
and they gave it to him yeah I was gonna
say I think it's like a good eye because
he did a lot of research and was like
okay there's mention of an earthquake in
the water we never really got onto that
if you just look into like a bunch of
Marvel like any of the Avenger movies
and you're just like okay that brick
that hit that building who could be in
that building and like just take that
character six years ahead of time you
can blow that world out and make it so
much better and we now have to use it I
mean we're probably going to use them
going forward a lot but it's also like
now we know there's people in the water
during all these things happening yeah
and there's so many great comic story
lines that involve now more and
um we're kind of done Black Panther and
things like that so it's like smart of
him to kind of put those dibs out uh and
it's worked out great and that kind of
dovetails with same same interview Nate
more talks about possibility for black
panther three we're about to get Mike
Panther 2 in in 10 days time uh but he
said there are certainly ideas we
floated around of what a third film
could be and we get to make it but until
this movie comes out we're a bit
superstitious in that way they're not
pulling one of these uh moves that
sometimes like streamers or TV studios
do are they greenlit season two before
season one where it comes out you know
or the way the animated shows try to uh
screw writers over by being like we
green little season two when it was
really just they ordered a lot of
episodes and now they're like yeah but
we don't have to pay you in a
consecutive amount of time we can do
separated anyway that's a little inside
base right here yeah nice uh Hollywood
dish Hollywood tea with Tommy B
we know they've they had this big
meeting right where they're like we
planned out 10 years and I'm sure not
everyone's at that meeting I would think
Nate Moore would be another one not
everyone's at that meeting well like not
every director gets to be there right
that's true uh and I'm sure it's
magazine can't make it it's mostly like
full-time Marvel Studio staff right and
they're planning it out I'm sure that
included a black panther 3 and that plan
but there's probably an accident there
is a Post-It note on a board somewhere
it was like maybe black panther throw
and even since they earned it even since
this phase five and phase six plan
rolled out at Comic-Con there's been
changes made to it right and shifts in
time and new projects and armor Wars
never on it but also still not on it and
also a movie now right things are always
kind of changing and shifting they
surely have mapped out a black panther
and the further we get into the uh phase
five and six plans right the thinner it
gets there's like bigger gaps between
the films it'll probably get filled in
yeah and so like though as of now this
would not come before what end of
2020. wait how far do we how far does
Basics go Basics go towards the end of
2024. there it is great so like I
thought it was 2026 is as far out as
we've seen anything slated
um which you know uh Hey beginning of
2027 it's only you know a scant uh four
years away basically 40 by then
now there was a lot that happened that
kind of delayed that movie but still it
takes a few years yeah every four or
five years is not not a bad pace for a
franchise and like we can only assume
this movie is going to make a gajillion
dollars and they'll want to make a bunch
of them how much is a gajillion I don't
know it's a lot of zeros we hope it
makes a lot of money and then people
watch all of our new rock stars content
oh found the film speaking of which Zack
if I may add if you haven't liked this
video yet or subscribe to our Channel
now's a great time to just poke on over
with your cursor and uh Tommy I think
you're the one that told me that only
simps don't like yeah it's real basic
you're a real basic simp if you don't
like super choogy to not like no cap
s
damn
um oh and I want to tease we're gonna
come back to Black Panther wakanda
forever Jessica has seen the film uh our
special guest has seen the film we are
going to be peppering both of them with
non-spoiler questions about the film uh
that they are going to uh not break any
ndas or spoil anything I didn't get them
on Kevin there's some really fun
questions uh don't worry about it um our
special guest is is motioning to me off
screen but it's not there drinking from
a cup and staring us directly and I want
to mention I my good friend gorgash who
shows me at Alleyway Cinema showed me a
copy of a movie called black banter
which is about a dentist who sits it
down in the chair and just disciplines
you four hours long full frontal the
whole time uh it was one of the darkest
films I've ever seen in my life I always
call him gorgash I don't know his name
was
no Gorge is my doordash driver Gorge is
my movie Supply that's okay so check out
black panther uh Adidas Wired Magazine
is going
okay
do you like that no no I don't like that
final headline
um Joe Locke who if you caught the is it
uh the Netflix series is Heart Stopper
on Netflix yes uh the Netflix series
Heart Stopper he's one of the stars of
that series
um he has been cast there he is uh he's
been cast in Agatha Covenant of chaos uh
we don't know what role he's playing yet
we were kind of speculate in the office
Billy or Tommy yeah they're gonna have
to age those kids up huh yeah because
the the actors they currently have
playing them if they ever want to do a
Young Avengers they'll never call it
that uh yeah
yeah
we're boring I had too much Halloween
John bring me some sugar I am your
neighbor
okay speaking of sugar crashes thanks to
some of our super Chatters out there
today Bucky Barnes ATL something do not
throw team okay
there's dogs around you that'll eat that
and die catching Straits Bucky Barnes
ATL say Bechtel my brother love y'all go
Browns go bills Anthony Hernandez was it
good last night Bucky Anthony Hernandez
saying we need tales of the Jedi contest
what are we getting I love you guys I
believe it's a breakdown Anthony
Hernandez you're in luck my man our own
Eric Voss has done a breakdown of that
that is coming out on the channel soon I
believe it's not already out today it's
coming out soon so hold tight Anthony
Hernandez and can you open that closer
to the microphone that'd be great thank
you so much
oh you're gonna disappoint me about
fidgeting I'm sorry Matt Savage saying
didn't Guero Del Toro write a justice
league dark script years ago for DC and
then nothing happened with it that could
be true that sounds familiar I have no
idea uh I'm so scared of scary movies
that I don't even read news about scary
movies or people who make scary movies
Adrian Rue is saying Jess you're a God
and I love your personality rest of the
crew much love always okay you're a God
thank you thank you uh Theodore Harris
oh and Angelica golodano saying wake up
wake up wake up
uh it is indeed but if you clicked on
this video you probably saw that
thumbnail we were thinking about old
Cassie Lang and I say old Cassie Lang
when this is his new Cassie Lang our
third Cassie Lang in the MCU uh
Catherine Newton the actress playing
Cassie Lang was kind of talking about
the motives of the character in an
interview with entertainment in tonight
uh she was pointing out that the
character is not perfect she's super
impatient she wants to be a hero but has
no idea what she's doing uh and like
that's kind of the motivation of the
character she's trying to figure out how
to be a good person and you know making
a lot of mistakes she's kind of a mess
really yeah and so am I Catherine you're
fine you're doing great you're working
in Hollywood she's doing really good
that's the Gen Z let me get on a soapbox
no okay come on come back to her come
back to him we've been talking about
like Cassie Lang in this movie and how
they you know they they age up a little
bit more since the last time we saw an
in-game obviously it was easy to age her
up with that like five year Gap it's
like boom she's older now she's ready to
take on a bigger role in the MCU but you
know they have this in the trailer
they're teasing that she's kind of like
thrown in jail like why is she in jail
is she just like acting out is is that
her thing like she's trying to be a hero
so she's trying to like do vigilante
justice on her own like her dad and two
things come to mind for me one our
introduction to Kate Bishop yeah when
she's kind of trying to do some
superhero stuff but turns into just
getting in trouble right like when she
shoots the bell tower at her college or
whatever right um and then two she has
Scott Lang's daughter right and to not
only is she the daughter of a thief
criminal type of character but she kind
of had an absentee father for an
important part of her childhood there
where he's either imprisoned or blipped
right so it's like yeah maybe she has
gotten into some kind of delinquent type
of stuff I'd believe that other than the
the latter or the other one that you
said because I'm like that's too close
to Kate Bishop's story and they look the
same so it'd be like it would just be
like the same story I like the idea that
um
oh shoot I just lost it come back to her
stepdad Bobby Kennedy he's a cop right
that's right is she acting out in that
way doing that stuff but if she is
following her Father's Footsteps right
maybe she's like stealing something she
has this piece of tech that she builds
that kind of appears to set off the
actions of the film with the quantum
realm and all that stuff well she's
stealing stuff to help finish this weird
piece of tech like is this her only
run-in with the law uh what we see in
the trailers is like the first time
she's been picked up or maybe she's been
acting out for a while now we don't
really know so I read what I was gonna
say I'm so sorry I love it I was gonna
say that I I like the idea that before I
know that the sokovia Accords are gone
now but if she was breaking into there
to be a vigilante and figure out who's
on the sokovia accordingly and doing it
into her own hands and doing a lot of
damage because we know if you get those
sokovia chords on your hands it's going
to just raise so many random Vigilantes
I think they're doing well but they're
not they're actually doing worse so I'm
like watch her be doing breaking in and
hacking into something A system that big
and they're like we caught you and also
the scope of your chords are gone it's a
big deal it's a big deal that was what I
remember but yeah so she's obviously
been acting out like going to prison
getting picked up or whatever I mean
she's not going to prison she's picked
up by the cops for doing something right
uh but who is she like working with
obviously because there's an important
line in the trailer right we yeah built
this but it was during the blip well
right it was like insinuated because
like she mentions that like during the
blip we didn't know what to do and we
were worried about you and we were like
oh if only we could reach out to our our
dad or something which is kind of
bizarre and maybe they'll establish in
this in the movie I don't know if she
knows where her dad was she might know
now but at the time Cassie does would
probably just assume her father was
blipped and not stuck in the quantum
realm yeah right well I'm sure it's
someone she met well I okay go on
because I know so she has this piece of
tech right and she says we built this
tag who is she working with to build
this Tech they haven't established
Cassie Lang as like a super tech genius
yet or anything and she says we so who
could she be working with she's in the
room she's currently in the room with
her father Scott uh Hank Hank is there
Janet is there and hope right
Janet Janet is it did not help are we
gonna assume Scott is not part of the
week and we don't know about Hank and
and hope Hank and hope we're blipped so
they're not helping during this blip
thing it's also weird this piece of text
she's working on if she started working
on it during the blip or they didn't
tell her dad about it until this very
moment seems very odd weren't they all
blipped but
um Scott because so all three of them
are gone yeah and then it's just between
Scott and her so it's like me and Scott
had to make this machine otherwise well
it doesn't seem like Scott's a part of
it yeah exactly so it's probably someone
off this list you create yeah may I you
got a question I'd love to interject
please who is uh who I refresh my memory
if you may uh those of you who remember
the the properties in Civil War who
brought on Ant-Man who who
Falcon Falcon who was attacked by
Ant-Man in the first Ant-Man film when
he goes he's like I know a guy that we
can bring in to help be on our side
because my question is during the blip
who would feel responsible from The
Avengers to check in on cash
zooms out assuming yeah so Falcon's out
so can't be anybody that was blipped
right maybe cap cap was around and was
part of that side of the team right
doesn't seem likely to be helping her
build something but he might be bringing
her into you right uh something Clint
was also not blipped and was on cap side
of the team and with no Ant-Man but he
was out killing people Tony was around
Tony was around but seems like he was an
isolation although wouldn't that have
been sorry kind of a sweet
way to reference like Tony
knowing that that Ant-Man was once a foe
of his right felt a responsibility to
check in on Cassie Lang and maybe get
some Stark Tech yeah because Tony Tony
and Scott were on opposite sides of the
Civil War but by the end of Civil War
Tony breaks them out of jail yes and and
hey they're both fathers of daughters
right maybe he sees like a little bit of
his daughter and and Cassie wants to
help her out he's like I haven't and I'm
not sorry I'm not anyone in the chat
today I'm not implying that a a male
adult needs to like Mentor this smart
young woman there could be a female too
I'm just asking the characters yeah
Tony's hanging out with his daughter
it's two years into the blip he's
drinking he's listening to John Mayer's
daughters on the radio and he's like
maybe I should go check out maybe I
should check out that guy's daughter I
don't know so I only fought him once so
who could be helping Cassie right a top
candidate yeah is Kane right yes if Kang
needs to get out of the quantum realm is
there a way he's able to help Cassie
from Beyond is he like typing on a
computer we were saying this is such an
uh fascinating thing this is my favorite
theory that King incepted this actually
yes basically right because we know Kang
wants them all in the quantum realm
because he needs to recruit Scott to
help him we think to get out of the the
quantum realm or to get something for
him or something like that so rather
than like a happy accident that they get
sucked in there somehow Kang puts those
events in place by uh helping right uh
Scott's daughter invent this machine
that will inevitably suck them into
because we do know you know uh Janet was
able to reach out to Scott through the
quantum realm now Scott had gone down to
the quantum realm and she was able to
put her
inside of him yeah but we don't know all
the weird rules of the quadrome and
seemingly this Kang is very Adept with
utilizing the quantum realm to get what
he wants so he might have been able to
build a device to send a signal to her
brain to build this other device could
there be even a scenario where like oh I
have this great online partner who I've
never met in person yeah yeah great G
chats all the time very very Incredible
Hulk right yeah yes I think it's a
different version of King okay that's
another idea right could it be a
different version of Kang there is a
character known as iron lad also part of
the Young Avengers at one point who
discovers that he's a king hates it it's
like I don't want to be a king they're
all bad how do you discover I mean I
have to take a mirror and you stand over
it you can't see that part of your body
no no any other way from your Kangas
yeah
so I think yeah I I think it's iron lad
I think iron-light like iron I like the
idea that's Iron Lab because I think
that's the big the big long game that
he's playing in the quantum Mania I
think it's like yeah I already had the
situated that my version of like my iron
lad would be the one that helped her get
that signal out to me that's stuck in
here because he is a master of time and
a manipulator of times I think he's
being able to do that but I don't think
iron lad's doing it in a place yeah
because iron lad never really wants to
be again yeah
just consciously like during the blip
met this girl that also is a big fan of
technology and they were like let's
build this thing like it was like hey yo
girl you want to see my Ram no you want
to see my motherboard nope uh I like
that idea what do we even throwing out
what if is there a world in which Bruno
could be oh no baby so Bruno's a very
smart little boy jilted lover
angry we met him in Miss Marvel very
smart uh figuring out what mutants were
uh built lots of tech built LED fingers
as presented in the show a mysterious
family we never meet his parents yes
he's a witch he also gets into an early
program at Caltech and we know that this
is a West Coast kind of story you know
airman's based out of San Francisco
that's not Berkeley throw in the chat
what city is Caltech Cal Poly Pasadena
yeah
are there not no several kills several
Cal polys they got satellite campuses
there's only one Mount St Marion let me
tell you that's a weekend I don't know
okay thank you to daschal uh Southern
California Residence
I have one more question I'm sorry is
there a chance that Bruno got into
Caltech through some nefarious like
someone was like well that this guy in
here that could be very much it'd be
part of the Inception right I need to
get Bruno and look out that food he
looks up with Cassie Lancaster they
build this machine it's a complicated
it's a complicated they mean on an app
called Kanger
isn't the 616 King he who remains is
that not our universe I don't think that
that was declared in the show right
because that was kind of Beyond
universes right I guess I always implied
that it was the 616's king I gotta keep
the other gangs out so you think the
scar Kang that we see in the Ant-Man
trailer is not necessarily the 616 no
because I think the quantum realm
attaches to all universes in like a
weird way uh
on a soda bottle of universes right and
that if you're at the cap you can go
anywhere in the soda bottle you want but
okay no cap
real quick this is a little tangent but
you're saying that what are the odds
we've seen more than one king in
quantumania I think we could zoom up I
think we're answering multiple we've
speculated on the show before that we
were assuming there's more than 1K
coming in yeah thank you uh I I don't
there's too many M's and a 15 in your
name but yes Bruno is the sidekick best
friend and Miss Marvel so yeah I don't
know who Bruno win yeah yeah
Geniuses we're about to meet Riri
Williams
ironheart in wakanda forever yeah no
known uh science genius uh Tech Builder
also a similar
yeah that's a lot of that's a lot of
Riri Williams in projects
yeah he's in a lot of places but also if
she's in Chicago so it's like she's
bouncing between Chicago she's in Boston
Chicago
all around there's also you know the
idea that maybe Hank Pam was helping her
because I do think I was on it I do
think it's weird on the trailer when
they're like all standing in there in
that room and Cassie's like we built
this and Hank kind of like smiling
there's a brief second you've been Mike
Michael addressing that that image okay
that's true and then Janet's like what
did you do and then Hank's like yeah
what did you do I'd like slowly backside
I think hangers got but I think it's
like because I think Scott's because
Scott is still kind of a dum-dum right
and so I think he's like yeah we did
this to make you guys happy and then I
was like no it's my it's interesting you
bring up Scott being a dumb dumb [ __ ]
is he a dump dump I don't know I I lean
towards the semi-dum-dum side where he's
not smart enough to build this device
they kind of established that he's good
with some technology like he obviously
built this scheme which he was able to
steal money from the company he used to
work for blah blah blah he's worked
security Tech I.T stuff he's able to
disable an alarm and in the first
Ant-Man when he's messing around with
the regulator and he tells Hank like oh
I think I can boost your efficiency and
Hank's like don't screw with that you'll
wind up in the quantum realm that was
like a plot device but at least
established that like Scott understands
some electrical engineering maybe if
casters like I have a plan for this he
could help her wire it right or
something like that
what are you doing Five Nights at
Freddy's oh they can't hear you I mean
you understand you're still being
broadcast
what I don't know what that means ignore
the chat you're the one tell me your two
co-hosts are talking about the subject
of this video and instead you are trying
to I was distracted momentarily sorry
yeah okay uh
thanks it's it's great to know that um
what I'm saying on this show is so
fascinating to you okay other other
smarty pants in the MCU that could be
helping her right yeah Spider-Man
absolutely not like he's in New York
she's over here they don't know each
other no way Peter Parker's helping
Bruce Banner
maybe maybe he's getting on conference
calls on his way back from he's back on
Earth he's got scar who
Bruce Banner oh oh okay I I thought you
said someone else and I was like why
smoosh manner uh Bruce Banner he's back
on Earth he's got scar he's looking for
stuff to do yeah I don't know he's got a
kid he's got a guy he's gonna leave his
teenage son at home
another thing he's never seen any Star
Wars movies I can't talk to him uh and
then of course there could be someone
from jail that she met maybe helping her
like hey you want to really mess some
stuff up
build this also with Kang and then it
could just
could just pronounce the true character
yeah brand new character I like the idea
of her also just bringing in a
a just third-party character like
someone we wouldn't we're like oh [ __ ]
we know we know William Jackson Harper's
in this movie we don't know what he's
doing yeah
he's a professor maybe he's her uh
whatever I know we've
the views and pre -titles before but I
think the idea of someone advising her
Virtua I mean just based on how it's
such a great parallel to the real world
where there are all these are not the
internet is so Anonymous right so people
can really seemingly benevolently
influence people but and then there's
like you know maybe it's a little more
allegorical for like the dangers of the
internet that a Kang will rise up and
take over your world but I love the idea
of like he can somehow the only way he
can blast out or broadcast from the
quantum realm is like via a computer
it'd be on like a specific computer that
he has to manipulate Cassie Lang to get
to because he knows that she will be the
one that will be young and naive enough
to build this device
or maybe the only person with the memes
yeah but the means to do it okay made it
to tick tock where he points to the
ingredients to build the content oh my
God that's radio device so funny but
also I think it would be oh millennial
anyways we are fascinated the the answer
to that riddle is going to be an
important one months away months away uh
but but to prepare for that moment you
got to be healthy right we all want to
live to see uh Ant-Man the WASP
quantumania the best way to do that is
to get your daily athletic grade yeah
that's right I love athletic greens it's
great they're ag1 I take it every day
just a one little scoop in a cup of
water Stir It Up delicious boom I get 75
high quality vitamins minerals Whole
Food Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens uh it's a special blend of
ingredients it supports a lot of healthy
stuff including better sleep quality
mental Clarity and alertness it's
something you can do every day to take
care of yourself uh nutritional
insurance right we got insurances for
our car for our houses for our boats
horses for our other boats our horse
Insurance uh pet insurance all that
stuff but that's your own body
nutritional Insurance boom uh and it's
super easy our good friends at athletic
greens they're going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune support and
supporting vitamin D and five feet free
travel packs with your first first
purchase of athletic greens ag-1 all you
have to do is visit visit
athleticgreens.com breakroom again that
is athleticgreens.com breakroom to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
delicious we thank you so much but we
also want to thank lands and business
have you ever gotten some free swag at a
trade show only to immediately hook that
into the garbage due to its poor quality
we'll make some swag that matters create
an extension of your brand that's ready
for anything with custom apparel from
lands and business I'm already a huge
Lands End fan as if I could become a
bigger fan I find out they got this
whole business bracket bracket get fully
customized clothes accessories and
promotional products featuring your logo
and colors elevated by Decades of
experience a Gucci to moochie headband
perhaps for your closest friends they
offer Timeless styles that fit every
body type with the widest range of sizes
you'll find in branded apparel you got a
seven foot tall guy that weighs 190
pounds they'll fit them see your little
girl and Vivid colors on t-shirts
outerwear hats mugs water bottles and
more hundreds of products perfect for
any trade show event or holiday gift you
hear that holiday gift season's coming
no don't mind they have customer service
that goes above and beyond every
business is treated like a VIP whether
you have five employees or 500 and you
can set up an online store where
employees can order items they need
without worrying about inventory that's
nice it works for you see why thousands
of companies count on Lands End Business
go to business.lands end.com slash
podcast remember it's podcast okay and
use promo code podcast for 25 off you
laugh but it's hard to remember we got a
lot of codes around it only behooves us
to use the correct code we want those
Sweet Sweet Lands End dollars that's
business dot lands end.com slash podcast
promo code podcast for 25 off your first
product
it's time for man fun wow
it's in the script it's man [ __ ] I
didn't put it in the script that way uh
you did we talked about I think we need
to summon our special guests okay hang
on
oh
oh I know that I know that call that's
why God that's Eric Voss is
[Music]
going to sue us it's a bird it's a king
it's Eric Voss
those are those are just all my tears
from when I was uh reading the chat too
much during earlier in the show oh you
can't read these things I don't read it
all they're salty I never read it I just
look at the pictures it's the Emojis for
me black panther black panther that's
what I do
goodbye everyone
[Applause]
first time you said something like that
you told me to say that black panther
wakanda forever not black banter uh or
black panther a huge movie uh that my
buddy Gore gosh I'm just trying to get
out gor gosh yeah it's a different guy
that's that's more gas
black panther wakanda forever you simps
it's here it's nearly here some of us
have already seen it Jessica you got a
chance to see it no spoilers
are you pandering to me no
we also have another member of the
office
uh the sneak peek gang here today let's
hear for everybody
I did get to see it early that was so
exciting but I just want to be able to
talk about it with you all early gang
well guess what it's not going to be a
little talk here it's going to be an
interrogation and uh we're gonna ask
some questions about the film and if the
conversation gets a little too spoilery
we'll move on but let's get to it first
question Brandon you want to ask it this
is a very serious question okay all
right
this is a two-parter if I may do you
answer the first part do the
download key hints I don't know
Cal Oaks do they speak underwater and if
they do do bubbles come out of their
mouth like
yes I forget that you can do an
underwater impression you're the only
person I know
you can do it he's just really good and
I don't
do it oh they do and they don't okay so
similar to that was a similar thing in
Aquaman right they could speak
underwater mouth bubbles don't they
I got that I thought they got rid of the
bubbles next question
do any of the characters eat during the
movie and if so what was the taste of
street food they ate in the movie yeah
do we see anyone eat anyone eat um yeah
some people gobble some people gobble
gobble gobble Thanksgiving scene
confirmed here first Thanksgiving in
wakanda wakanda celebrate Thanksgiving
every day because they're grateful
thankful people unlike us who only
decide to be thankful one day a year no
there's some five proxy I am
thinking I looked you directly in the
eyes I didn't mean to listen
you know my character I'm Canada in the
MCU I'm the Black Panther oh
[Laughter]
there you go okay so there's some eating
yes any interesting Foods
unexpected Foods
um I think expected Foods unexpected I
think eaters oh wow
there's unexpected food whoa yeah it
looks like we have a little disagreement
next question
do they have toilets
yeah I don't think they have uh there
was never a scene where nemour was like
excuse me I need to go to the bathroom
no but there were moments were no more
just kind of like stop Smith's sentence
and like looks off into space
and the water gets warmer uh what's the
what's the convention with toilets and
Cinema like in the 1950s they never
showed a bathroom before psycho was that
the rule yeah so before then toilets did
not exist in any Cinema to be fair the
bechtels didn't know toilets were real
until they finally got on TV so we were
just going everywhere that was the 19th
yeah we had we had crapping tents and
every corner of the room had a little
tent in every movie every time there's
like a villain I'm always wondering like
what's it like when he's going to the
bathroom
Joker on a toilet like sure
we've never seen Elena Bulova go to the
bathroom we've never seen well well we
can't as men we cannot ask I bet Vision
has uh
the Big Green Goblin just took a squat
in an Alleyway somewhere
by that I'm also fascinated by like
truly diabolically evil non-powered
people in like in movies yeah it's like
cut to them just like cutting a little
TV dinner up and being like my gotta eat
I'm starving
yeah but um well while speaking of
people that we've never seen go to the
bathroom on screen uh answer the
question is does Spider-Man appear in
this yeah
hmm sometimes can you tell sometimes
what I mean who knows who knows who
knows if he's like behind where the
games are so invasive what are you
hiding Spiderman could be in this
episode of the break room right now and
we wouldn't know I mean it's true in
fact there are probably some spider
logos around the room who is Spiderman
where is Spiderman next question well I
mean we know Spider-Man exists we just
don't know that's right yeah who's in
the shoes under that
listen to me have you seen there's
someone on Tick Tock that was dressed up
as Miles Morales but their afro was too
big so it made like a giant love and
they're like how does Miles Morales get
his afro underneath the hood and now
they're doing the math to figure it out
this is I think that's totally fine how
many minutes into the film does it take
every K Ross to reveal himself as Dr
Doom
I would think first five minutes yeah
that's gonna be a first time how long is
the movie about two hours 41 minutes six
and a half hours three hours and 40
minutes
if he's sitting next to you at the AMC
or whatever you know I'm doom
you just brought up the length of this
movie I think this is a question Tommy
and I were talking about before what
what is the amount of soda you can drink
during this movie yeah and survive
without without a bathroom break that's
how you can person uh how you were gonna
I drink it in time how many times am I
gonna blast you guys threw a large you
got there like soda no bathroom break
yeah I don't usually go to the bathroom
during movies
how long is the gap between when the
first credit rolls and when the last
post credit scene is over is this like
you're sitting there an extra 10 minutes
you're sitting there for two minutes I
feel like uh Multiverse and Madness we
got both of them I think it's around 23
minutes it's it's pretty long but here's
the deal you don't feel time is the
constructs right it's relative and you
are so transported by Rihanna Rihanna's
music that you don't care how long it is
oh my God
song is oh my God we get it you saw the
movie do they name check the break room
do you want us to answer your question I
don't want you to answer my questions
with more questions and wistfully
remembering the soundtrack together I'll
tell you that for dang let's physically
fight
while I'm here mommy please
um this is taking them back to my my
parents divorce and I cannot handle it
yeah it's starting uh now we heard at
the premiere right they only show the
mid credits
and thing did you get two post credit
scenes or did you only get one
uh I feel like a child at the doctor
with their parent I keep looking at you
for an answer right and then I say I
don't hit her
yeah
there's one reason why a kid ever does
that that's why you get the kid it's
because they put vitamins in the butt
instead of the mouth there's one what
you guys never heard that what I was a
Flintstones there's just one there's
just one do it again but I'm telling you
the credits are so good to sit good it's
beautiful and like there's hey I am
since I started doing this job I read
through all the credits because there's
like interesting stuff that gets
revealed by who plays whom there's
little cameos sometimes and you can see
in the credits like oh I didn't realize
that that person was related to this
person you said something on Twitter
that was like about the movie and I
remember hearing people talking about
what you said about the movie uh in the
theater and they were like I can't find
what Voss saw and I was like Jesus
Christ I didn't even think about that
you know what because I said something
like World building Galore or someone oh
the the uh hierarchy of power and the
MCU is it's definitely changed which I
firmly still believe we'll all talk
after you know we've seen the movie and
I will point out exactly what I refer to
but I um I think a lot of people are
going to come back to me and be like you
son of a [ __ ] that doesn't that doesn't
matter to me but in my opinion it
matters a great deal okay so this is I
think the question that's probably going
to blow the door off this whole
interview is there an ironic moment
where like a young wakandan says No Cap
meaning don't call Sam Wilson but it
could also mean this isn't true this
question I think you know the answer
though
okay
call back to what are those do they
bring back that popular menu of 2018. I
don't remember meme I don't I think that
would have been a great opportunity hey
you know this is a different shuri I'll
just say that I want everyone
yeah I was like skin wise no absolutely
not this is a different
actresses they do say sporty stuffy a
lot no they bring up ashy a couple times
they need some geology Friday I would
love to Circle back to Tommy blasting
piss is there a way that you can say if
you see something happen can you say
something that starts happening on
screen it's a fair time to go blast some
piss no you're not alone
I hear like movie podcasters sometimes
say oh I go to the bathroom in the
middle so I have to see movies multiple
times it's like you shouldn't be doing
this okay camera four real quick sorry
real quick this is very important I I
know I get it I'm interrupting a lot
today I had too much Halloween candy
this is super important guys clip this
out for social media as well here's your
life hack for if you have to pee to when
you're watching a movie okay you go to
Home Depot you buy 200 yards of tubing
you put the tube in the urinal you
attach the other end to wherever you go
you sit in the movie and you just flush
it safely down into the urinal will not
work all you got to do guys that will
not work uh well has the break room been
like this
something been like this you should see
this is this we're under control right
now this is turning we're acting
dignified in front of you also ultimate
way to help yourself it's not a frequent
viewer of the break room I've been
working on all that yeah let's pull
should Eric be watching the break room
every day
they're all going to be like no make
more breakdowns they're going to be like
what happened to rings of power
I'm working on it just keep coming up
keep it coming up Nina's right you
should just wear a diaper oh I was gonna
say is it official break room new
Rockstar's policy go in dry that's right
don't drink anything before anything be
a little Cactus baby I feel like so you
guys go to the bathroom actively a lot
during movies no I try to avoid it but
sometimes I read a lot of pain by the
end of the movie yeah it's pain
sometimes my guts are screaming
oh
I was asking Zach for a reason not to
during
eternals too I made it the whole time
they were on the volcanic island too or
the first eternals I was like what did
you see that way during the whole during
the whole Volcano Island fight I was
just like get this over with please
someone okay the first post credit
happened and I was like okay I'm gonna
run to the bathroom and I couldn't stand
up straight
across OverWatch my prostate's that big
the turtles during the journalism I feel
like a journals just hit people like
that they were like I need to use the
bathroom because I remember I when with
my ex at the time and he left and he the
line was so long he didn't come back
until the sex scene and I was like you
didn't miss it oh yeah well I had dry
boys at the theater this week I saw
someone like leave right before uh she
gets taken up to Airship and it's
explained the whole thing and they get
back and I saw the person lean over and
their partner be like no I cannot
explain what just happened who's missed
the entire explanation of the movie I
know the question about what kind of
forever okay so
um does Namor get a Mr freestyle style
like classic one-liner like he he
knocked somebody out or he killed
somebody and he's like time to throw the
baby out with the bath water looks like
you're all wet he actually does say
motherfucker's always trying to ice
skate
get soaked shout out to uh blade Wesley
Snipes Wesley Snipes jumps in somehow I
don't know why Ryan Cooper did that when
does blade come into the movie uh around
1 36. I try to do a gotcha questions any
great classic one-liners from a
character uh I mean in this movie I
don't know I feel like he says too many
iconic things for it to be one classic
one yeah I would say they're my favorite
line of the my favorite reveal of the
movie comes from no more oh he goes he
goes Splish Splash now you're taking it
back
yeah the water lights on fire somehow
from his cigarette everything he says I
think Tanaka words is it's a notch who
works I keep I gotta correct myself
there to make sure to Instant Star in
this movie I cannot believe that this
guy I mean he hasn't seen nombre but he
was in he was in the freaking elevator
inspector in the opening long take scene
with Daniel Craig and then to noteworth
is just another guy making out with
another girl that's like the first time
we all saw him and to see him go from
that to this instant star this guy's so
so good in the movie
um I saw him and when I went to go ask
the wakanda Forever cast questions I
can't he came out the elevator while I
was going in and he was like sorry and I
was like you're beautiful oh he was
gorgeous and he's amazing I've seen him
do elevator scenes now in person oh
you're watching we watched the live
performance of the elevator yeah he just
hangs out by the elevator so people were
like okay there's a TMZ photos I'm sure
where I'm in the background because of
that thing uh well guys we we have to we
have to focus this up uh do you think
there's too many superheroes in these
movies all right no I'm just kidding
Zach and I are wondering on a scale of
Manchester
how excited should we be for the
post-crediter or end credit scenes
excited
um I would say tamper your expectations
it's not the kind of it's not going to
be the one that makes you go let's go
well I don't know some people might go
let's go to that actually I retract my
statement I think some people are going
to be freaking pumped okay I really
liked it but it's because of the full
essence of what the movie is yeah it's
perfectly like rounded at that is it a
kangaroo fighting a human yes okay how
did you did you already see the movie I
was trying to think what would make me
go let's go at the end of a movie and if
a kangaroo was boxing human okay I'd
stand up with my scene go let's go is
the dog eat him yeah
no one but one person okay
um final
spoiler free then a review but like can
you just tease a random detail out of
context for us
like like keep an eye out for left turn
signals or um uh you know there's 64
Black Panthers and I'll name them all
for you or there's an odd number
number and for us to guess if it's one
three five whatever oh my God on their
Prime yeah I guess
um I'll say read the new stickers
working for big Chiron again very nice
um not a spoiler but once again uh cops
are useless in MCU Fair yeah it's a good
pod device to not have uh authorities be
helpful yeah
um wow thank you so much to Eric Vaz for
joining thank you Eric you're you're
around for a while we may see a little
more of you this week that's right yeah
you should all be watching every day all
day and if you haven't liked this video
yet remember I have a database of all
your addresses and I'm very lonely these
days so I'll come over to your house
I'll pants your dad foreign
[Applause]
Christian unpronounceable did send in a
Super Chat and you guys you don't have
to answer this because you're on embargo
but do you guys think tiama will be
mentioned in wakanda he got a little
shout out finally right
but actually everything out
we're going to the oceans yeah and he
kind of popped up out of here I think if
his head was over by like the South
Pacific then his foot should come out in
the Atlantic right I think a split
should come out in like uh more like the
Pacific or something
because where did he wasn't he in the
core of the earth well that's crazy and
Celestial was in Earth for the entire
gestation of the for at least what how
many years
it was before it was parties where was
Abraham the beginning of the place we
see the planet and then we see it oh
sorry geologists in the MCU be ashamed
of themselves for never noticing this
giant alien they're like wait a second
they barely make it oh my God is that a
pair of balls
[Applause]
did you just assume too much gender
yeah I did oh wow that's me could be
lady the Black Panther okay on that note
thank you all so much for watching thank
you everybody in the Super Chat Tonya
Tyler Quentin Shea H uh everybody
yeah Mario and DK soccer kid
Mario Mario and DK wants us to do a
WrestleMania watch along well we can't
because we're gonna freaking be there
yeah if you see us there say what's up
uh Mario uh all right everybody have a
great rest of your week we'll be back uh
tomorrow same time same place
cheese
[Music]
sorry if you guys